شارابوفا Lama Olek النفور telefónica
Herrera de hiatal إلى موسكو ، أنت تعلم
أنك في القاهرة عندما تستمر في السير
في الشارع والناس يحدقون فيك ليس
فقط الرجال ولكن الفتيات أيضًا ،
والشيء الآخر هو في Equipo ، مرحبًا هناك
الشوكولاتة نفسها مرة أخرى سأكون  عادي
في الرياضيات ، لديك سرعة قريبة من l3
cojiro ، فأنت تعلم أنك في القاهرة
ولا يمكنك المشي حقًا في الشارع إلى
فستان
Seraphin ، عمود اثنين من المشاهير
حيث توجد منطقة مأهولة بالسكان مع
رجل أكثر خبثًا
لعنصر Telefonica ،
ونأمل أن يكون هناك درعان للهوايات  تحرك من أجل a la
magie بالقرب من كابل Lima Pazhani Luthor
المغربي ، المواد هي AMA لإخبار
الكابل في جولة مع الصياد
زارافا كاتب العمود O'Connell صالح تنازل
Jehan Sty Issa في هذا الملف مرة أخرى هنا
بالتمني بشار إلى Winnetka لماذا هو
دبوس قفل ما لم  يشاهدونه وأنت
تعلم أنك في القاهرة عندما يسألك سائق سيارة الأجرة عن
سبب عدم التدخين